un fuerte temblor de tierra despertó en
la madrugada de este miércoles a
guatemala y es que de acuerdo con el
servicio geológico de los eeuu con
posteriores revisiones del instituto de
sismología y vulcanología de guatemala
el sismo registró una magnitud de 6.2
con por lo menos 25 réplicas posteriores
entre las que se destacan una de
magnitud 5 y otra de magnitud 4.8 el
epicentro del movimiento telúrico se
ubicó en la costa del océano pacífico
frente al departamento de escuintla a
por lo menos 100 kilómetros de ciudad de
guatemala y de antigua donde nos
encontramos y es que aquí lo
experimentado fue un violento
estremecimiento que puso a mover
lámparas farolas incluso camas y puso en
alerta a toda la población
afortunadamente según la coordinadora
nacional de reducción de desastres no se
registran ni víctimas mortales ni
tampoco heridos pero si derrumbes graves
colapsos estructurales en por lo menos
siete departamentos del país derrumbes
además en carreteras que conectan a
guatemala con el norte del salvador y el
sur de méxico y es que guatemala de por
sí es un país que frecuentemente sufre
este tipo de sismos de movimientos
telúricos por encontrarse en una zona de
riesgo en la que confluyen tres placas
tectónicas